Joel and Ethan I'm going to start with
you I'm curious if the precipitating
idea is literary cinematic I see there's
a reference to a Jack London story in
your credits where does this story begin
for you
yes the well that Tom Waits story ogo
Canyon is the one story of the six that
that we didn't write that's pretty much
that's a very faithful adaptation of
Jack London's story so that certainly
was the inspiration for that was
certainly literary the literary or
cinematic I you know as far as the other
ones are concerned you know there have
been things that we've done that are
have much clearer sort of literary
antecedents and I think this other five
stories and this doe on the other hand
and yeah I would say it's fair enough to
say that certain of the stories are we
were consciously thinking of you know
specific genres of of western movies the
James Franco one being you know sort of
more of this sort of Sergio Leone or
spaghetti western type of thing and in
just in a general way we were thinking
about other genres you know the ones
that take place in a stagecoach the ones
that take place you don't covered wagons
story that sort of thing
but beyond that not really does that
mean that within each individual story
you find yourself more free to stick to
a certain way of storytelling that if
you don't have to have a cohesive theme
across the entire spectrum of the story
you can focus on some narrow convention
of the genre within each story more
closely
Ethan's mulling thanking rejecting a
green I'm thinking um I don't know I
guess you're kind of talking about
subgenres or something I don't quite
know the reason the reason I was
thinking and don't quite know what to
make of it is cuz we I guess they're all
genres stories in a way but we don't
really think of them as genre stories we
just think okay you what would be good
here and what would be good here is
informed by er having seen a lot of
movies and read a lot of stories and
that's all been kind of internalized but
we don't actually yeah we don't really
talk about genre per se so it's kind of
hard that's all kind of that this kind
of discussion is very much ex post facto
well the other thing is if you take the
first story for instance you know you
could say well that's clearly that
generically that's pretty clear it's a
singing cowboy movie but you know we
were only thinking about singing cowboy
movies in the sense of singing cowboy
movie and that's as far as the the
interrogation of the genre went you know
and then we kind of made it up from
there so Mary I want to ask you about
your collaborations with Joel and Ethan
but I really want to talk about the
first costume you got to design what it
was and how that set kind of a design
template for the whole rest of the film
well I started in chronological order
and sort of proposed an idea for Tim's
but it was all based on what the
character was written on the page and
and then went from there I mean I did it
in chronological order as well but I
didn't like do one costume and then get
the fabric and it's sort of it's a it's
an evolution like first you start with
research and then some character boards
and then we have a meeting and then I
start pulling and we built we had a sort
of a measurement / fitting with Tim
tried some hat shapes on him can I go
this far
was the question and and then we met him
again and we had the final we had to we
had an another in person meeting with
you guys and we sort of went through all
the stories and they're great they're
very able to imagine how things are good
look going to look with like a sketch
and a pile of fabric and we just divided
all the stories on like table tops and
our prep and our shop in at Western
costume and then you know we had
mannequins standing in for Tim and
that's how that's the approach but they
were you know yes I did start with Tim
but I was also thinking about the rest
of the film at the same time if you look
really closely in the text in the story
of something like the mule ticket it
says that he has a bearskin jacket on
how much of that you're laughing so I
noticed that that that liam's coat is a
really interesting that's an amazing
piece of yeah fabrication yes is it
written into the script this is what
he's wearing or you having a dialogue
this is what I think he should be
wearing
how specific are the cues you're getting
from Joel and Ethan in that kiss I don't
remember something about this it said a
bear skin coat but he's not wearing a
pair of skin coat but it was implied
that it was a big furry thing by that
description in the script what it
actually is is sheepskin rugs from Ikea
dyed all the same color and shaved where
he's wearing an Ikea rug about you have
to build it himself there are 30 they
were really small it's a long long story
I thought it was hysterical when I found
out that's great it really it looks
great I mean it's it really looks ready
that was the key your characters written
as a singing cowboy
he's also a dancing cowboy at what part
part of the process did with that reveal
to you that you were gonna oh the dance
when I got try to get to a set no sooner
than one week early but on this one
because
of everything I needed to do two weeks
early and thank God because that the
second day Joel said by the way we're
adding a dance number and we have a
dance teacher who's going to come in and
work with you and then that was every
day and then the dance got changed the
day of and I really thanked my lucky
stars for actor training in many dance
classes because I was able to give them
what they wanted in changing it but you
know that's the greatest part of an
actor's life is is constant challenges
that differ from role to role that's
it's what we live for
and you never get that like you get it
in a Coen Brothers movie Carter there
are two things that tie these stories
together
one is the visual landscape and the
second is the oral landscape that you
have to knit together a soundscape
that's going to tie these stories
together and also not only reflect kind
of the genre and the conventions of the
genre but also do something new so where
do you come in do you start with a
particular story or do you step back and
say this might be the overall theme to
the film and it's gonna change in these
particulars ways for these particular
characters well I think before they shot
we had some casual discussions about the
different chapters as I recall at some
point someone said and could you'll tie
it all together somehow basically and
then when they got back from shooting
that tying it all together became like
that was the most important thing really
it seemed at first so um I did attempt
to find something some some thread that
could be put through it all because I
guess at that point you know it's been
written it's been shot the you know the
only thing that can be done at that
point is with music and I have to say I
kind of failed yeah you know I did tried
a lot of different
to to you know to do that to thread it
but the stories are so different the
look so different the tone so different
that it was you know it just felt forced
every time I would try to do something
like that they each of them really had
to be their own thing and so we in the
end we came up with this the idea of at
least bookending it so at the beginning
when the book is open and at the end
when the book is closed we use the
streets of Laredo tune that brendan
gleeson sings at the end it seems
completely appropriate a song a
well-known song about death that's known
as a cowboy ballad you know but yeah the
idea of like somehow really unifying it
all as a canvas I've never quite you
know was able to do well you know it's
interesting because it was a dissimilar
discussion with Carla that we had with
Bruno because just from visually how
much we should your cinematographer yeah
this in my tog refer in terms of you
know how individualistic the looks of
the different stories should be as
opposed to maybe they all have the same
look for instance but the great thing I
mean that really I mean that's part of
what's and again cut we've been making
movies with Carter since the very
beginning I mean one of the things is
that allows you to do is and it was
evident in this process I think is you
go down certain resin and it kind of
declares itself you know what I'm which
direction you should be going but you
have to be doing that with somebody
who's going to understand at the same
time you do how it's declaring itself
what the proper solution is and that was
really kind of in a way this was an
interesting movie in that regard because
the discussion was about that yeah I
think more you know more than other
films we've done we didn't understand
how much the structure was going to
complicate it honestly I don't think
that we really foresaw that when you get
on set and you have a chance to act
opposite actors that drillin ethan and
their casting directors have picked what
does that change in terms of the
dynamics of performance that you are
essentially almost it almost feels like
you're doing
in some ways well this was a very
special one for me for the obvious
obvious reasons but also because Bill
heck and I did Angels in America
together eight years ago now we played
husband and wife and that and so when I
saw him in the lobby of the building
that we went for a callback I was pretty
excited because I felt you know we have
like six months of doing Tony Kushner's
together which is like going to war
metaphorically I obviously know nothing
like going to war but you know it made a
big difference for me just having
someone I really trusted and Granger
Hans who plays mr. art there is also a
really lovely dude and it did feel a
little bit like a month of just being in
this tiny company of actors the way it
feels like when you're in a theater
company thank you so much
[Applause]